[Music]
this video is brought to you by wires
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
from gamestop to wall street bets 2021
is set to be remembered as the year of
stock market madness
but now there's been another event that
rocked the industry
family fund archigos capital management
has become a landmark cautionary tale
about risk management and grief
after suffering devastating losses in
the billions
bill huang the man at the center of the
scandal is an interesting character
he was once worth over 30 billion
dollars and on track to become one of
the richest people on earth
though with his car of choice being a
hyundai he wasn't your typical
billionaire
starting in 2013 bill used 200 million
dollars from a previous venture
and turned it into 20 billion and then
in just
two short days it was gone no individual
has lost so much money so quickly the
fallout from this event
sent shockwaves through the market
causing significant losses to share
prices
and a handful of banks lost billions of
dollars and top banking executives have
been fired over the scandal
so what went wrong who was responsible
and what have we learned from one of the
biggest financial blunders
in recent history sit back and relax as
we dive into the story
[Music]
bill huang was largely mysterious to the
general public and even the financial
industry
it would be only former co-workers and
his church members that knew him well
despite huang being worth billions he
only drove a hyundai suv
and lived in a suburban new jersey home
this was a clue into bill's mindset
being a devout christian he didn't
believe so much in material wealth but
did
indulge in casino-like risk a paradox
but a key part of his undoing
in 1982 bill immigrated to the us from
south korea
he was the son of a pastor and raised by
a widowed mother
he eventually earned an mba at carnegie
mellon university
in 1996 after being a salesman at two
security firms he landed an analyst job
at tiger management
the hedge fund tiger management was
started by julian robertson
an absolute legend in the field and bill
huang was his protege
to truly understand huang it's important
to recognize
just how successful his mentor was
julian robinson was the titan of hedge
fund management
his career saw him turn an 8.8 million
dollar investment from family and
friends
into 22 billion over two decades
50 former employees of julian went on to
create their own successful hedge funds
this group would be known as the tiger
cubs obviously because they worked at
tiger management
and these tiger cubs were the best of
the best
even among this elite class of investors
bill huang stood out to julian robinson
huang's performance during his time at
tiger management was so
impressive that in 2000 as robinson was
stepping back from fund management
he gave huang a substantial initial
investment to open a new york-based fund
focusing on investing in asian markets
in 2001 bill would unleash his
aggressive investment style in the form
of tiger asia management
tiger asia management grew to become one
of the biggest asian market focus funds
in the united states
turning an initial 1.2 billion dollars
into 5 billion
at its peak former clients and
colleagues at tiger asia
who spoke to the new york times say that
bill concentrated his stock picks on a
few select names
and used borrowed money to increase his
position
according to a former employee bill was
secretive
often concealing particularly large
holdings from his own analysts
it wasn't until 2008 that attention
began turning towards his risky
investment style
as he was one of many fund managers that
was stung by the monumental volkswagen
short squeeze
rather than an extensive diverse
portfolio it was clear that huang's
success
relied on a lack of diversity an
investment style that would eventually
be his undoing
in this case bill huang was betting
heavily against a small number of
substantially shorted stocks
things would get worse for him too in
2010
it was discovered that huang was being
investigated by u.s security regulators
this was over a suspected insider
trading scheme involving chinese bank
stocks
two years later he pleaded guilty to
criminal fraud charges
admitting that he used confidential
information for the basis of making
profitable trades
these illegitimate profits amounted to
16.2 million dollars
in the wake of the controversy bill's
hedge fund tiger asia was ordered to
forfeit 16.2 million dollars as well as
a further 44 million dollars to settle
in a separate legal case
huang decided to accept responsibility
for his actions and return outside
capital to investors
although pleading guilty to fraud and
insider trading
to the banks huang was still seen as
somebody who could make them buckets of
cash
and for that reason they were still
willing to loan him massive amounts of
money
he just needed another venture to get
back into the game
after closing down tiger asia he turned
it into a family office
it would be at this point that archigas
capital management was born
archigos became the christian family
values fund of huang's dreams
everything from the name which in greek
loosely translates to prince of christ
were influenced by huang's christian
views
huang said that his intention to be a
great investor
is all for the purpose of benefiting
society and pleasing god
he claimed that the insider trading
charges revived his christian
motivations
and he now would use his wealth to
sponsor christian organizations
throughout the us and south korea
regarding these donations huang said
quote
i'm decreasing the amount of money under
my name in order to do the things that
god loves
claiming quote i do it because i like
god more than i like money
with quotes like that you would think
that bill would play the market safe
but his strategy was anything but safe
it's in god's heart and it's my heart
that a lot of people in investment
community and these companies
would know the reality of god and then
creating culture which is god honoring
you know serving one another
and learning doing
where it's not all about money
you know but it's about long-term you
know god certainly has a long-term view
and it's all it's really helping a lot
of people learn how to invest well
and use capitalism to
to help human societies advance
in the grand scheme of things bill's
trading strategy was strikingly simple
akagos would borrow a bunch of money and
stuff it into stocks that bill believed
would go up
stocks such as the chinese internet
search giant baidu
shopify and viacom cbs after doing
fundamental analysis
that is focusing on world trends and
studying companies financial statements
he built a highly concentrated portfolio
around his stock picks anyone on
reddit's wall street bets can pretty
much do the same thing
except in bill's case he had hundreds of
millions of dollars in borrowed money to
play with
with an initial sum of 200 million
dollars from his previous venture
huang spent the past decade investing
successfully turning that 200 million
into an estimated 10 billion
but the thing is while archigos managed
to amass 10 billion dollars of its own
money its positions were valued closer
to 30 billion dollars
thanks to a little trick called total
return swaps
and this is where the story begins to
get really interesting
while total return swaps aren't illegal
they are considered a risky
controversial way to boost profits
they're investment contracts
brokered by banks that enable investors
to take large positions without needing
the funds
front essentially in a swap a hedge fund
pays the bank a fee
to gain exposure to the profit or loss
of a stock
without actually owning the stock itself
it's all based on the trust and
understanding that the borrower can
cover the positions if the stock doesn't
go in the right direction
these return swaps also had the added
benefit of hiding archigossa's name from
appearing on the books of financial
dealings
an outside viewer would only see the
bank's name holding the position
not archigossa's name according to the
new york times
even the firms that finance bill's
investments couldn't see the big picture
this is how bill huang and his archigos
fund managed to stay
so secretive in the united states there
are rules that prohibit the purchase of
financial assets with over 50
borrowed money interestingly
no such limits apply to hedge funds and
family offices
so archigos went wild and consistently
increased their leverage
to begin with it was an amount of around
two times
or borrowing one million dollars for
every one million dollar of capital that
they actually had
but by late march the leverage level was
over five times
and where bill huang took the extra risk
was in the number of banks that he had
the swap agreements with
due to the archigas reputation each bank
trusted bill huang
and trusted the archigos had the
collateral to be able to cover the
positions
but what each bank didn't know is that
they were one of many
six in total goldman sachs morgan
stanley
credit suisse numara deutsche bank and
ubs
each bank understood the risk that they
were taking individually
but not as a whole
by scattering his share through multiple
return swaps archigos was able to make
loads of profit without revealing
themselves as major investors
and as crazy as it was this extremely
risky bet was paying off
while the hedge fund's actual capital
rose to an estimated 20 billion dollars
the potential raised through swaps
exceeded 100 billion dollars
luckily for archigos things were going
well and would continue to do so
as long as the market moved how huang
predicted
of course it didn't
before we continue i just want to give a
shout out to today's sponsor
wise as you're all probably aware the
traditional banking system has its fair
share of drawbacks when it comes to
international dealings
if you're a person that's looking for a
fast and cheap way to send money
overseas
whether for business or family wise
formerly known as transferwise
makes it easy wise is seven times
cheaper than traditional banks
with no hidden fees you can send or
receive money instantly
in 50 different currencies between 80
different countries i've already used
the service myself
when i had to pay for some illustrations
while i was writing my new thinking book
by clicking on the link in the
description you'll get a free transfer
of up to 500.
clicking the link helps support the
channel so thanks
[Music]
by march of 2021 arcagos and the six
banks
held substantial long positions in a
handful of successfully performing
companies
but things started to fall apart when
bardu and far-fetched share prices both
began to drop
and on monday the 22nd of march viacom
cbs which huang held a 10 billion
stake in announced an upcoming sale of
common stock that caused a massive
sell-off
and a 20 dip in the share price bill
huang's risky investment model
was suddenly unraveling a few bankers
pleaded with him to sell
shares as he would take losses but
survive avoiding a default and a total
wipeout
huang refused if the stocks in his swap
accounts rebounded
everyone would be fine but if even one
bank flinched and started selling
they'd all be exposed to plummeting
prices it was a game of chicken
with very high stakes the losses began
stacking up
and archigos started selling off other
stocks in its portfolio to offset the
losses
but this caused a problem in doing these
actions bill huang
no longer had the collateral that had
given the bank's assurance in the first
place
archigas had lost the leverage that
convinced banks to offer the return
swaps in the first place
the banks wanted more money as
collateral and bill didn't have it
[Music]
it wasn't long before the banks noticed
that archigos wasn't going to be able to
cover the collateral
in an attempt to minimize losses
representatives from morgan stanley
goldman sachs credit suisse and nomara
met to discuss the best course of action
credit suisse and namara who knew that
they would face the biggest losses
suggested working together slowly to
undo the damage over the course of a
month though
ultimately the banks failed to reach an
agreement and it became a race of panic
selling
the next morning without consulting the
others morgan stanley threw the other
banks under the bus
goldman sachs would be next as they
believed the market would catch wind of
the situation within days
and the losses would maximize this quick
action and going behind the other banks
backs
led to both banks being able to avoid
major damage but their massive sell-offs
triggered a further decline in stock
prices
by the time the other banks involved
managed to move the now toxic shares
the damage was done
credit suisse says it will lose 4.7
billion dollars
and now have removed two executives from
the company over the incident
nomara will lose two billion the other
banks got off lighter
but not lightly it has been reported
that between the six banks involved
and estimated 10 billion dollars was
lost
according to bloomberg bill lost 20
billion dollars in two days
and bloomberg described the situation as
one of the most remarkable failures in
modern history
it is truly a historical loss of wealth
in such a short period of time
despite this huang is optimistic about
the future of archigas
insiders predict that the family office
would inevitably file for bankruptcy in
the near future though
well look this is devastating the
losses they took versus everybody else i
know that the risk control
chief has been traded but i think the
whole management has to go
i mean this is one of those things just
unforgivable if you don't know how to
handle
a busted uh client then you shouldn't be
handling anyone
and this is uh it's just a really dark
day for credit suisse
wow uh this is remarkable and
i i think that credit suisse has to
completely reevaluate itself and i think
the uh
i think the regulars have to re-evaluate
them i'm not sure they know what they're
doing
the global fallout from this blunder has
sparked renewed conversation about how
family funds are regulated and monitored
it is estimated that family offices hold
assets in excess of 6
trillion globally twice the size of
hedge funds
despite these staggering numbers details
of family offices
are largely hidden both from the public
and regulatory authorities
disclosure requirements for family
offices are extremely minimal compared
to hedge funds
and could be insufficient considering
the power they possess to influence the
global market
after the global financial crisis of
2008 the united states passed the
dodd-frank act
this dramatically tightened regulations
for the financial industry
but due to the cause of the crisis the
securities and exchange commission
exempted family offices this kind of
makes sense on paper
as angelo robles founder and chief
executive of the family office
association said
quote if it's their money they can do
what they want
just like the average person why should
they be disclosing things
end quote but incidents like archigos
call into question how much control
these unimaginably rich families can
have over the direction of financial
markets
perhaps there should be a monetary
threshold where above this amount
you're required to disclose more
information bill huang's actions have
cast a light on the need for tighter
regulation
heightened transparency and a
reassessment of the inadequate laws that
govern family officers
in a time where wealth is becoming more
concentrated each and every day
something needs to change if we are to
have any hope of something like this
never happening again
in the grand scheme of things it can
also just show how temperamental stocks
can be
especially if you're playing a risky
game
with such extensive leverage and little
diversification
bill huang was playing the casino and he
lost
big time
so if you watched the previous episode
on the 11 billion fraud that was
worldcom
you might be interested in this next
tidbit i had someone from the cold
fusion discord mentioned that he knew
bernie ebbers
he had been to bernie's house and took
note of just how insane it was
according to this discord member bernie
was a nice guy but just stupidly wealthy
i thought it was just some interesting
insight if you want to join the cold
fusion discord and have a chat about
video topics and many other things
links will be in the description so
that's it
thanks for watching if you want to see
anything on business technology
science or history be sure to subscribe
to cold fusion
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good
[Music]
it's me one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]